[Music]
LiveTV got the best of today host
Savannah Guthrie Wednesday morning as
she dropped the S bomb on air sorry got
the sound guys quickly cut Savannah's
Mike it wasn't bleeped in the original
airing and it's unclear if Savannah even
knew she was live on air during the
moment though she did take to Twitter
after the show to address the blimp
writing quote check check this thing on
yeah I guess it is so sorry guys thanks
for being kind and understanding and
guess it's a good thing I don't wear a
mic all day hashtag oh darn and that
kind of honesty is why we just love
Savannah you'll be successful if you're
just authentic in yourself and hopefully
be a good person I think that's what's
needed in this world in any industry I
think that it's such a privilege to get
to host the Today Show and I think it
really exceeds any kind of dream I ever
had for myself so I feel so thankful and
there's not a day that goes by that I
don't have that thought and I actively
tried to always remember that when I
come in in the morning I try to remember
you know this is a pinch myself kind of
situation if you told me five years ago
ten years ago that I would get to do
this I wouldn't have believed it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]